smell
[Music]
the travel
journey freedom
no you know it's not like deeper deeper
i'm guard hollinger i'm keanu reeves and
we're here as a
representative of arch motorcycle and
we're doing some audio
recording for cyberpunk 2077.
arch motorcycle is a custom production
motorcycle company what's unique about
it is that
the motorcycles are built on a
production platform
but each one is designed to be able to
be personalized
for each customer
[Music]
when uh cd projekt red approached me
about doing cyberpunk 2077
they also spoke about integrating they
were fans of the
i guess people who worked at the company
were fans of arch motorcycle and so
they broached the idea of creating kind
of
specialized cyberpunk 2077 version of
the arch motorcycle
and i thought that was a very fine idea
[Music]
we have a motorcycle we've we've
designed and we've been developing
called the method 143 and so
that i think in particular was was um
a creative inspiration for the designer
so they sort of use that as a basis and
then went further
so it has a totally different crazy
looking power plant
we did a little customer that's good i
like it
today we're capturing sounds getting
some actual
sounds of a power plant drivetrain and
characteristics of the motorcycle which
i'm sure they will
you know have play with and stuff but
the source will be pure
it has a sort of a racing engine in it
compared to our production motorcycles
it has a dual exhaust system
and it sounds pretty
i could definitely blindfold to tell
that
that's the method 143-ish sounding
motorcycle yeah
nature of the role-playing aspect of the
game i think it'll be cool like to be on
a bike and hearing that
going city streets and getting into the
madness of mayhem
foreign